we're not scared of any army on the
other side of the border that's the
message from ukraine's president in his
new year message one clearly aimed at
russia and there was more defiance
unfortunately we have not ended the war
in the east of our country yet this is
our primary goal that's why i say not
yet because next year will definitely be
better
according to ukrainian officials there
are currently around a hundred thousand
russian troops near the border western
governments say they're concerned about
a full-scale invasion
the fighting in eastern ukraine between
separatists backed by moscow and the
ukrainian army started in 2014 as huge
protests in the capital kiev led to the
pro-russian government being overthrown
the conflict has killed more than 14 000
people devastating ukraine's industrial
heartland known as the donbass and
leaving civilians terrified
earlier this week the russian and u.s
presidents had a phone discussion
lasting nearly an hour and involving
threats on both sides
i made it clear to the president putin
that
he uh he makes any more moves and goes
into ukraine
we will have severe sanctions
we will increase our
our presence in europe with our nato
allies
and uh it will have to be a heavy price
to pay for it
but our president immediately responded
that if the west decides in this or
other circumstances to impose the
unprecedented sanctions mentioned that
could lead to a complete breakdown in
ties between our countries and caused
the most severe damage to relations
between russia and the west
russia is worried by what it says is the
west's rearming of ukraine and it'll be
taking part in a series of meetings
starting in 10 days time
it wants legally binding guarantees that
any future expansion of the nato
alliance will exclude ukraine and other
former soviet bloc countries
it's not clear at this stage where any
compromise will come from nadine barbara
al-jazeera